joined now by the former Northern
Ireland secretary Lord mandelson very
good evening to you lord
your reaction overall I mean he may be a
political opponent but do you think
Richie sunak's done pretty well here
both in the the content of this
framework in effect rewriting the
protocol and in its presentation so far
well I warmly welcome what's been
negotiated and what's been achieved uh
it has always been my view that the
original Northern Ireland protocol would
not survive contact with reality on the
ground in Northern Ireland and I've said
that consistently I mean the essence of
the original protocol remains and that
is you know no reinstatement no
reappearance of a hard border between
north and southern Ireland and that's
very important for the peace process
very important for the Belfast Good
Friday agreement but in every other
practical sense
the European Union has now agreed some
very major uh changes I think its
original approach uh was far too rigid
far too literal uh in in the
arrangements that it was applying and
now it stepped back uh considerably and
of course in the process it's uh I mean
uh not the stuffing out of Boris Johnson
who I who I'm sure would love to have
found ways in which he could beat his
successor over the head uh with this new
agreement I don't think he'll be able to
do so he hasn't got a leg to stand on
that is because the agreement really is
now as good as it gets
and just on that you mentioned Boris
Johnson there I was going to ask you why
do you think the EU has become so
accommodating do you think that's part
of the the issue that they just couldn't
get on they didn't trust Boris Johnson
when he was prime minister and they they
do Rishi sunax built or taken down those
barriers built those bridges
well I mean Boris Johnson did not
negotiate or agree anything in good
faith uh I mean he he didn't tell the
truth about the agreement uh that he had
made I don't think he ever had any
intention of standing uh behind it I
mean having in effect thrown the
unionists under a bust as they
originally saw it he just sort of tried
to pretend that oh you can just sort of
walk away you can ignore it it doesn't
matter about this agreement
um with sort of fatal consequences
obviously for our uh partnership with
the Republic of Ireland on the island of
Ireland but also disastrous uh too for
our future uh trust and relationship
with the European Union and what's
important about this dermit is not only
do you now have a workable agreement in
the Windsor framework which will be very
good indeed uh for the people of
Northern Ireland it also allows us to
repair the British government's
relationship uh with the Irish
government and it also allows the
British government to start rebuilding
trust and uh and uh and a relationship
that we need between ourselves and the
European Union both economically and
also for our future defense and security
but are we in danger of getting a bit of
ahead of ourselves here because there
are still potential sticking points here
particularly from the dup's point of
view and and that is the involvement
perhaps at the margins But ultimately is
the ultimate Arbiter of the European
court of justice
you'd have to look very closely in the
rear view mirror to catch any site of
the European court of justice no I I I I
mean I'm very familiar with the you know
the seven conditions
um laid out by the dup and I think all
their conditions are met and one thing
in particular is important Dermot as I
made clear I've said so before on your
program and I made clear to my former
colleagues in the European commission
Before Christmas they had to involve the
Northern Ireland assembly and their
executive
in future changes uh to EU rules as they
apply to Northern Ireland this dormant
break which has been introduced is
really very important it's a major
concession by the European uh Union I'm
glad they've done it uh and I it it
effectively takes away in my view the
last grounds for any resistance that the
dup might have to what's been freshly
negotiated and agreed